welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
boss and spider-man no way home burst
the marvel multiverse wide open but you
know what not wide enough because
despite green goblin blowing up that
machina dika dhamma da da dama
dabadabados to crack purple reality
riffs in the sky nearly inviting
hundreds of awesome multi-dimensional
cameos into the mcu doctor strange and
peter parker just had to slam the door
in all of their faces don't they know
that um we have an open door policy in
this house of em at least to everyone
not named ralph boner because we already
have one
i have seen no way home five times in
imax and still trying to make out every
single one of those glowing silhouettes
is tough
who is that pokemon shocker it's pikachu
however i could actually make out quite
a few of these several more than i
initially spotted in my big ol easter
egg breakdown wait wait a minute 10
million views holy scooby-doo
thanks everybody but let's break down
the new cameos i found and what that
tells us about the plans to introduce
these characters in future films and
before we begin thanks to true bill for
sponsoring today's video more about them
later so when the rifts crumble across
the sky around liberty island from the
other side of those cracks appear
countless glowing shapes most of them
know bigger than stars but you can start
to make out their shapes in three to
four shots of this film first when the
three peters look up at the sky toby
maguire peter thinks he's dying and sees
people in the sky and then we first see
a wider shot showing several characters
in that rift then we punch in closer on
a few of them and then a moment later
tom holland peter swings up to doctor
strange atop the statue of liberty where
there is another wide shot and then one
final punch and closer on a few more
characters the most prominent among all
of these is a figure holding a spear
with thick shoulders this is craven the
hunter the spider-man villain that the
no way home screenwriters actually
initially cited as the villain of
interest for this third film when
they're writing it but in the months
since cast by sony as mco pietro maximov
actor aaron taylor johnson for an
upcoming solo film most likely gonna be
based on the amazing craven's last hunt
comic i think we can expect craven to
take place in that sony
villain-dominated side universe of venom
and morbius morbius a movie that was
just delayed from january to april
perhaps to give them time to include a
cameo by andrew garfield spider-man
since that morbius trailer did show the
garfield continuity oscorp tower and
graffiti of spider-man as a murderer and
andrew garfield peter mentioned falling
into a violent streak in his timeline
then again morbius will also feature the
mcu michael keaton vulture well maybe
that was a sloppy spill from this
reality into that one when all those
riffs were happening or maybe just
another confusing example of some
variants looking like the same actors
across different realities as we saw
with jk sims j jonah jameson we will
know in april but if you look right to
craven's right there is a figure on all
fours with a curved tail this is spidey
villain the scorpion now i'm not sure if
this is a matt gargan scorpion played by
michael mando and spider-man homecoming
whom i presume would have a more tech
heavy mechanized suit the way michael
keaton's vulture did in that movie this
looks more like the comic accurate
scorpion who often goes on all fours to
scorpion's right is a more slender
figure that actually matches the shape
of black cat felicia hardy another title
sony has had in the works for a solo
film for quite some time we actually saw
felicia played by felicity jones in the
2014 andrew garfield amazing spider-man
2. but if you go back over to the left
of craven is a smaller figure with four
extended arms coming out from the back
who aggressively jerks its head to the
side on first glance this kind of looks
like carnage who does extend tentacles
from his symbiote anatomy but it also
kind of looks a bit like the spider-man
doppelganger form created during the
infinity gauntlet storyline who goes on
to join carnage and shriek and maximum
carnage but ultimately i think this is
most likely the superior spider-man
incarnation in which otto octavius swaps
his consciousness into spider-man's body
and operates a suit with iron
spider-esque arms it's actually a pretty
great storyline that takes place in the
616 continuity so with the new year upon
us lots of us are going gonna try to get
our finances in order our money should
be as well organized as those funko pops
on the bookshelf and those bad boys are
lined up by genre age and color scheme
our friends at truebill are here to help
put some order into the disordered
finances of our lives and to set you up
for a good 2022. truebill is an
all-in-one finance platform that helps
you save more money and spend less the
personal finance manager allows you to
manage subscriptions lower bills monitor
your credit score and build your savings
all in one place i really like how easy
true bill makes it to safely and
securely identify recurring charges and
cancel the unwanted subscriptions with
just a tap bye-bye cheese of the month
club sayonara's second hulu account that
i didn't realize that i had true bill
helps set budgets that automatically
monitor your spending by category get
friendly notifications when you've
exceeded your budget and visualize your
spend to earn ratio over time get
started with trubil today by heading
over to truebill.com
new rockstars or by clicking that link
in the video description that's
truebill.com new rockstars but the
second shot of the rift shows a
silhouette that you probably caught a
bulky figure turning a head with a
prominent horn this is of course rhino
and actually maybe a more comic accurate
version of the character than the paul
giamatti alexa sistevich that andrew
garfield peter mentioned fighting back
in that 2014 film but then to the right
of the rhino is a harder to pin down
slender figure this person is a rounded
head that many have described as
mysterio's fishbowl helmet but seeing
still images doesn't really do these
justice you really have to see them in
motion and to me it's really the way
this figure steps so timidly toward the
rift with some adolescent awkwardness
really i think this is either gwen stacy
spider-gwen or miles morales both of
whom have slender builds and rounded
heads shaped by their masks considering
the other silhouettes placed prominently
toward the front are all big names that
sony has in active development i think
electro and andrew garfield peter's
discussion about a black spider-man
somewhere out there points to this being
a miles morales from another universe
now of course there is a miles morales
in the mcu mentioned by his uncle aaron
davis in a scene in homecoming when he
said he had a nephew in the area and
then in a related deleted scene when he
called miles by name but in this case
this could be a live-action universe
where miles is already spider-man now
there are some other silhouettes in the
periphery that are a lot harder to
define and we probably won't know for
sure until no way home comes out on 4k
but you can begin to discern some shapes
for example in the shot of the rhino to
the left there is a character walking
leftward across the frame who has a
shape protruding from his head looking a
bit like loki's curved horn headpiece
sure while loki is an mcu property not a
sony one this whole sequence was brought
about by dr strange's multiverse magic
and i would not be surprised if the
movie's artists mixed some mcu
characters along with their sony ones
and that loki series introduced us to
countless loki variants at least one of
whom must have known that peter parker
is spider-man and that walking figure
passes another character that strikes a
familiar pose while aiming a weapon
almost looks like a bow and arrow we
could be looking at a variant of hawkeye
or kate bishop or taskmaster or bullseye
but i don't know striking that pose it
also almost looks like an iron man
variant extending his repulsor arm but
the shape i was most interested to spot
is visible only when the peters first
look up at that craven rift the
brightest figure on the far left of that
lineup which looks like a slender seated
figure with a number of arms twisting
out from its center and an interesting
hairdo coming out from the top of the
head this could be madame webb cassandra
webb a psychic mutant who sits at the
center of the web of life's destiny that
bridges all the spider verses together
as we expand further and further into a
live action spider-verse madame webb
would be the figure you would see
peering out from an interdimensional
rift like this and with that little
mysterious moment of peter's
spider-sense able to bypass the magic of
doctor strange as peter was in his
astral form i think that's a little
indicator that all peters could share a
cosmic arachno frequency that stems from
madame webb in this silhouette's
position in the front of the line leads
me to suspect this could be her and if
those rumors speculating that sam raimi
directing doctor strange to the
multiverse of madness could be a way we
get tobey maguire peter parker to come
back for that multiverse event i hope
coming along with him through that
multiverse is his psychic mutant mama
you can support new rockstars by
checking out our merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at ee boss follow
new rockstars subscribe to rockstars for
more announcements of everything marvel
thank you for watching bye
[Music]
you